hey guys be any day back in Rosanna's
kitchen table and Gina actually sent me
this story this morning and I thought it
was pretty great so I want to do it an
airline stewardess can I quote the cold
stewardess is the attendant a flight
attendant doing badminton is that
offensive I offended somebody probably a
flight attendant a wonderful wonderful
woman thanks Jake a wonderful woman she
wrote a piece in Huffington Post sort of
laying out all the lingo that flight
attendants use which with each other to
describe themselves to describe what's
going on on the plane and going on with
the passengers and it's a great list
that we wanted to read a couple of them
for you so first up is a Deadhead and
that's when a crewmember flies as a
passenger but does not work on the
flight because the airline needs to get
them from one location to another so
that's that's a dead and I've heard that
like a suburb like I got a dead head
back to Seattle and I'm like what what
is that what is jam bands what to do
with anything that sounds like a pretty
inefficient way like you'd think at this
point with computers now I really may be
able to get everybody like wherever you
go I can somehow get you out of there
but now it's just not you got a dead
head it's not the case what else what
oh this one I favorites uh if you're a
gallery Queen you're a flight attendant
working in the ghetto I'm sorry a galley
Queen yeah galley
how often do we I'm not a pirate sorry
I'm not used to saying galley yeah
that's what a flight attendant working
in the galley position who's very
territorial and won't allow uninvited
guests to step or lounge in his or her
office I do notice that a lot like
they're very protective of that back
area they have access to the juice back
there right some of the other Fort Knox
but I take that very personally because
I got to get out of my seat man or I
will lose it Rico yeah I got to sit on
that aisle or I will lose my mind and I
got to do a little stretch and a little
hi how are you and if they shoot me out
of there I am screwed yeah I'm not a
great flyer actually and I have a flight
to New York in a couple weeks and my
flight going I am in a middle seat oh
man that's a to me that's better than a
window seat because then you're really
like and then you can see the gremlin on
the Wegener exactly the colonial woman
churning butter and I am convinced that
if I fall asleep next to a window seat
that side of the plane will fall off
welcome to this yeah that's that's a lot
right yeah
let's see what else they got
crop-dusting now crop-dusting you may
know a crop-dusting is it's a it's a
common term in regular society - that's
when a flight attendant walks by someone
and releases gas now that happens
commonly waiters do it regular do they
well just people do waiter people are
walking and farting and so it's as I'm
digging into my flan somebody I'm
getting crop-dusting very bas what else
baby Jesus it apropos for the season
yeah this is an infant passenger whose
parents treat it with the utmost
importance which may result in a lack of
polite behavior to the rest of the cabin
oh yeah I mean the baby people
everywhere like there's a jillion
stand-up it's about this but the baby
people don't care about anybody no it's
just all about the baby however I did
read an article this morning saying that
you are not as a parent supposed to hand
out little treats and goodies to people
saying I'm sorry if my baby cries we're
adults we don't need candy we should
understand the babies cry right we want
money I think is the I think is the
point exactly
a miracle flight is when elderly
passengers require assistance to board
the plane but miraculously do not we
need wheelchairs anymore when it's time
to leave that was pretty good you know
that you're gonna see that all the time
like people in the cart you know they
have those modified routes or whatever
that is now being driven by an airline
employee and they don't look that old
they don't look that infirm yeah
but they just want the ride yeah you you
feel like a VIP that's pretty good um oh
this is this is kind of weird this gets
kind of cultish the crash pad this is an
apartment or home that crew members
share as a spot to sleep between flights
sometimes with up to 30 beds or more is
that that I would like to see a flight
crash pad and see what the vibe is but
it's like a key party it's got to be
completely nuts right like all these
people coming and going I feel like
they're probably better they probably
they're all hooking up but actually well
back in the day they used to be smoking
hot right you know it's more inclusive
yeah
and clearly people that aren't smoking
hot never have sex okay crew juice is a
special beverage shared among crew
members during an overnight stay
usually concocted from ingredients found
on the aircraft but you didn't hear this
for me according to the woman who wrote
it so I don't know what she's saying
there the entire reason why you just
take whatever you can
like let it sit in a cheesecloth over I
think so yeah like they're just making
any sort of alcoholic beverage that they
can put together that's not very
reassuring yeah not an safety I can't
believe this didn't as a precaution
didn't make the list don't ever drink
water that isn't bottled coffee or tea
because the tanks and those things
haven't been cleaned since like 1962 all
right hot bunking oh yeah it's actually
originally a military term for when a
crew members bunk has been occupied by
someone else just before them so it's
still kind of hot like when you sit in
somebody else's seat and it's warm yeah
that's kinda gross later one they don't
want to be around at the slam clicker
which if I had read fast would it
sounded like saying okay a crew member
who doesn't socialize during overnight
stays but rather be lines for the hotel
room slams the door and doesn't come out
that would be an idea slam clicker yeah
just these they you know they work and
then they were I don't know respect yeah
like you work as long as you do your job
right yeah I don't want to go meet you
down at the Hilton lounge for a dollar
cocktail yeah um the coach Roach a crew
member who really enjoys working in the
coach glass god bless you good that's
where you're gonna find me so I'm happy
to see you you know what I've never sat
in first class in your life in my entire
life
then well that's basically true one time
a company thing did get me a first-class
ticket but it was a flight from Detroit
to New York and the plane was so small
that all first-class meant was that I
was in the first seat oh that thing is
that but there was no special you know I
don't I'm a believer that the people in
first-class they should board last
because I don't think they should have
to look at us yeah you know yeah I'm
pressing yeah they sit there and they
have all their fancy stuff and then they
have to watch us yeah that you your poor
your tired your it sick yeah it's like
at Ellis Island oh they should be
subjected to us or at least it should be
one way glass where they can gawk at us
but we can't see them because I don't
like making eye contact with them and
then it's like oh you saw my Sadler
although I think it's the other way
around they would rather enjoy their
champagne coulis while they watch us
walk by but we're not allowed to look at
though we're not avert your eyes
so either way can either way oka a
crotch watch this is a when I attended
walked through the cabin doing a
seatbelt check that is called a crotch
watch that's
next time pretty straight forward and
finally landing lips are used when
applying fresh makeup before the plane
lands which makes sense because you know
you get the bye bye bye goodbye watch
The Ellen bit buh-bye you like that want
them to be expression old-school yeah
any other any final thoughts on this
list uh it's a job I'd never want to do
so I appreciate that you know somebody
out there wants to do it I like to
travel for free but and not as an
indentured servant there you go
are you guys big Flyers do you like to
fly next time we'll do a little bit more
on personal flying habits let us know in
the comments right down below